I don't care if you're a cop I don't
care if you're a waiter I don't care if
you're a lawyer
or a janitor if your industry is being
threatened unjustly stand up for
yourself
yep listen man I've had cops with that
mean that's going around it's like if
have you ever noticed if you haven't
done anything illegal then the the
police leave you alone uh-huh I'm like
yeah right yeah right when I was sitting
in my apartment in Chicago and the cops
kicked my door and at gunpoint came to
me my three friends while we were
playing GTA what did we do what we did
nothing illegal they were looking for
somebody else and they broke all the
laws nothing happened happened about it
yeah when I had a cop pulled me over and
lie about me speeding what did I do
illegal nothing but I'll tell you what
my complaints over having negative
experience with cops my complaints over
the cops who are enforcing
unconstitutional decrees from their
governors is is irrelevant to the
conversation of about whether or not we
need police right police reform hey
maybe cops shouldn't be enforcing these
unconstitutional orders and when you
have a conversation about that hey maybe
they are bad cop too sometimes do bad
things and it happens more often than
you realize we should have some reform
there's been a big conversation about
non police first responders it's exactly
what I was talking about before some
kind of civil guard or community
response you know you know division that
can handle fines petty offenses parking
tickets and then the cops can you know
spend their time dealing with more
serious offenders and things like that
as a complicated conversation around
that but but we're actually having a
real conversation about the
reform-minded net my negative
experiences with police i've got like
one or two positive experiences and then
like seven or eight negative ones yeah
I've got a few negative most experiences
myself but but to put today I don't care
I mean I've I've dealt with people that
I'm I that have scared me you know I I
was on the subway and some dude pulled a
knife on me because I was wearing new
shoes that's so weird
and he looked at me he was like I'll cut
you and I was like I was just sitting
there I was not talking I didn't even
notice him I noticed the blade in his
hand and then I looked up and he was
deadlocked with me and I'm like what's
going on yeah and the only did he looked
at me right in the eye and he stepped on
my shoe a new shoe and I was like wow
okay I have what am I gonna do you know
fight you know but I would have I don't
know I don't know what I would have done
but it's crazy look man people are
there's crazy people out there I've had
I've had bad experience with cops but I
think it this way when the cops kicked
my door in man without a warrant and
came into my apartment with me and my
friends with their guns with their guns
drawn saying ass they were asking for
some guy and we're like who like what
are you talking about you like where is
he where is he when we were like we'd
moved in here a couple months ago if you
came to me and said you were gonna put
those guys up for the death penalty or
20 years in prison I'd like whoa whoa
whoa wait whoa dude yeah the guy
illegally entered my house I don't know
like suspend him or something well
imagine if when my friends got killed
they came in and then shot your friend
oh yeah that's a they could they
committed a crime
felony breaking and entering a gun with
weapons and then shot an innocent person
but what if what if your friend started
fighting him because and they didn't
realize they were cause matter they
still committed crime Oh God
if they break the law then I think
there's I think they should be hold held
to a higher standard if they break the
law so what look I mean let me ask you a
question though about this say they let
the guy run away you don't think that
they could have gotten in their car and
followed him and been like dude we know
where you live he's been arrested for a
DUI like they could have knows like what
no what they couldn't done it because
they were he was actually fighting them
well well it's you got a you got a guy
was drunk mm-hmm point 108 commit in the
commitment in the process of committing
a felony offense yeah who got violent
with you and successfully fought off two
cops yeah that's messed up who has a
history of beating apparently being
violent with other people yeah I think
his kids he steals a deadly weapon which
that which Atlanta just deemed they said
you got to understand taters are deadly
weapons he fires at you and in that one
split-second moment you get to decide
does he have a weapon is he gonna kill
me he tried to kill me well I don't know
his intent is will gonna hurt someone
else will he take someone hostage so you
gotta get my initial assessment was let
him go the problem then is what happens
if he runs and grabs a woman and puts
the Taser on her neck and says get away
from me
and I've got a hostage looks like he
dropped the Taser it looked like he shot
it
and like any man shot line Li that's
true yeah he got shot so I'll tell you
what man I've been at how many how many
of these people who think they know what
this cop should have done have ever been
in a situation where their life was
threatened none of them none of them
none of them I mean you've seen crazy
everybody has seen crazy videos of cops
not not police brutality videos I'm just
talking about plain old cop videos of
stuff that they're going through that
they have to deal with well we had that
one viral viral video that's insane let
me probably let me pull up the story so
this this was actually brought up James
Woods tweeted a video of this we can't
play the video it's hard to watch it's
very hard to watch stuff and I'll tell
you what this video is about take a
story out man who shot troop around
route 33 gets a bit 110 years in prison
fortunately that both cops survived
here's the story they pull the guy over
two guys are trying to arrest one man
the one man starts fighting them and
actually you know gets off of them they
draw their tasers and tase him he breaks
free pushes them down and they don't
draw their weapons still then he does
and he shoots both cops you know and
then you watch one of those cops with
his hand covered in blood
struggle to climb over a guardrail and
roll to get to get what's called dead
ground at an angle where he can't be
shot and this guy leans over his car
still shooting at the cops yeah gets in
his car and fires up the back window
several times and then speeds off they
see videos like this this is what I
every single cop when they're getting
trained sees this kind of stuff and
they're like this is worst case scenario
you need to prepare for worst case
scenario because any situation can go
into a worst-case scenario and and it's
like okay that makes sense when seeing
this it's crazy that guy got tasered by
both of them still fought them both of
them had their tasers on him he don't
want to shoot him though they didn't
want to shoot of course
right who wants to kill somebody well
you're gonna get shot then that that
probably marks you and in your brain you
know that probably never leaves you you
know here's what happened here's what
here's the problem with a bunch of
stories about cops who got scared for
stupid reasons you ever see that video
where the guy gets pulled over and the
cops like you got a license I and ID
yeah I got it right here and he reaches
into his truck and the cop goes aah and
touched shooting him I have seen that
I'm like will you told him to get it man
what are you doing yeah
now those cops need to be like put on
desk duty permanently it's like dude
damn all right there there is a real
question about when the the difficulty
is if the cop really was scared for
their life and we asked them to enter a
situation where they could be put in
harm's way and they overreact and panic
can we really hold them criminally
liable for being scared and pathetic
it's it's a hard question but it
typically leans towards the no like when
it came to fall and Oh Castile right
legal gun owner yep and the cop got
scared because he was reaching his says
don't grab your gun and then he shoots
him that's a very murky situation
because you have a guy who has a gun and
a cop who panics yeah so should the guy
go to prison for that or be stripped of
his powers and removed there's there's
it's the line is so fine I'm not gonna
pretend to know the answer but I can
tell you in this instance at least with
Ray shot Brooks we it this is this is
this is clear-cut use of force yes well
you said it already though all these
people that are saying they shouldn't do
this they should baba baba blah blah
blah none of them knows what it's like
to to be a cop none of them to be in
their shoes and deal with this kind of
stuff where anything can happen that you
can even a knife I mean I fizz is is
even more deadly because you don't even
see it coming you know that not just
they don't know who knows but as soon as
you start resisting and fighting them
like their minds instantly get well
pumped with adrenaline because they
suddenly are going from you know on edge
to actually fighting like who knows oh
man this [ __ ] gets me Mythbusters did a
video on bringing a knife to a gunfight
and they found that the average person
yeah notably themselves who are like
middle-aged and overweight dudes a knife
is more deadly than a gun yep yep and
that's something that I like how close
the distance right I reckon about what
was it 21 feet or something like that
Wow
24 he can pull the gun or the gun could
be drawn from the holster and fired wow
he was able to tag him with with a knife
so people people don't realize that they
often say like don't bring a knife to a
gun
fights like actually depending on the
distance bring both well no it's a knife
is is a guarantee if you're alright if
you're in close quarters a knife is a
guarantee a gun isn't you can't run out
of bullets if you're using a knife yeah
man I've watched videos unlike night
knife training stuff too yeah they're
like you see in the movies when they
swing the knife and the guy grabs the
rest and flips him over and then I
watched a video on like actual knife
fighting and the guys like don't believe
the movies man no and he's like let me
show you when it with a practice knife
yeah whoa man in like three seconds
you got five lethal wounds just like
with an untrained person swinging a
knife and jabbing and stabbing you can't
stop them anyway in the Rashard Brooks
instance you had an audible instant
regretable case yeah
we have asked this police officer to
enter into a situation where his life
could be in danger
violent offender committing a felony you
know drunk aggressive steals lethal
weapon death penalty for that seriously
you know these people these people who
are who are saying that he should he's a
murderer and stuff they don't even know
the story they didn't read any of the
news I saw one of my high profile I have
a friend who's like celebrity Lefty not
only that all the news isn't all the
facts aren't even out yet right
they're just surface looking at the
surface whoop yep all things are
narrative let's run with it go all of
the activists are saying he was sleeping
in his car to Wendy's and the cops shot
him right that's it's like ridiculous
wait a minute like you left out the part
where he was pulling out a weapon and
shooting him and like no no no wrestling
their weapon away from them and shooting
at him yeah yeah so I did have a thought
so I wonder if the cops in the parking
lot at this one days worth thinking
about this video that we just watched
yeah when they were pulling your weapons
and they were like I got no choice this
guy not only did he get away from both
of us now he has our taser
he's tearing off into the neighborhood
so what's gonna happen if I don't shoot
him
like am I gonna be dead too or Miami
shot whatever happened to those other
guys or like you said
is he gonna grab a hostage and whole
Taylor to there don't know their face or
whatever it is but it's it's it's not
even about these questions you know why
because it is a fraction of a second
when you see the Taser being pointed at
your face yeah and
and then he in the video you see him
switch hands and reach for his gun when
he swings the Taser back yeah the taser
fires and then he goes pop pop pop
someone's aiming the Taser at your face
yeah how about this one first person
foremost the cop had no I it's it's a
fraction of a second decide we'll use
will you wait to see what happens no
he's trying to kill you but think about
ridiculous what would have happened if
that if if Rashard got the Taser on him
and he dropped down paralyzed and then
Richard grabbed his gun right exactly
you can't look as much as people don't
want to accept it when the cops say
you're under arrest you put your hands
behind your back and you shut your mouth
Rashard Brooks should have shut his
mouth yep and this is for everybody not
just him when the cops are asking
questions what are you doing what he
doing he could have said just fell
asleep or because I don't answer
questions yep and then when they were
like you wanna do a field sobriety test
I don't yeah I don't answer questions
well how about a breathalyzer I don't
answer questions yep in a jail cell now
he would be maybe so so depending on the
jurisdiction I don't know how Atlanta
works but I think in Illinois if you
refuse field sobriety and a breathalyzer
they can arrest you and then force a
breathalyzer at the station right but he
wasn't he on parole he's on probation or
probation yep okay I mean look if he had
if he if he if for no right I don't know
the first mistake that was made in this
whole circumstance was Rashard Brooks
driving drunk end of story
the next mistake was him resisting
arrest for committing a felony I'm
pretty sure DUI is a felony right yeah
absolutely
so listen man I just got to say it if
you get caught don't do the crime if you
can't do the time this guy wanted to
drink and drive and risk other people's
lives and he he got caught at that point
you say you got me officer put your
hands behind your back and enjoy your
ride downtown
yep shouldn't do the crimes but instead
he said I'm gonna make everything worse
these cops knew who he was
they caught they knew his name oh really
yeah and apparently they heard they
called him backup because they knew he
had a violent history oh wow
I don't know if that's just more of the
what I heard all I do know back is on
the way right it was yeah yes they think
they when they found out who he was they
had decided to call in backup and death
penalty men so the I guess the big
question is we've already seen police
across the country resign just straight
up about a lot of people are saying duis
are not felonies they're not families
and I think what that means is there's a
certain blood-alcohol limit that makes
it a felony I think they're they're
saying they're saying the first some
people I think it's usually a
misdemeanor DUI is a misdemeanor I think
what about your second your second yeah
DUI yeah maybe I'm not not I have a C
we're not lawyers we don't have no I'll
tell you I'll tell you I'll simplify it
if you commit a crime can you get caught
committing that crime right don't fight
the police and steal their weapons yeah
if you get caught
dude this listen I really hate it when
the left trice uses arguments you know
you're not I heard they're like man you
got to understand when they watch videos
all day every day of cops killing people
they get scared and they run for and
they resist it's like what are you
talking about the videos are them
getting killed for resisting like that
look not every single video but I'll
tell you what we do have a big problem
and it's social media Europe so these
these cops who watched this one video
and then they assumed it could happen to
me it's like bro there's 375 million
interactions in New York court in the
NYPD union okay and almost all of them
positive don't assume that guys gonna
shoot you what to do well it's there I'm
thinking it's it's like in their
training they they have to know that any
situation could result in someone
pulling a gun or a knife out you have to
be prepared for that yep so especially
when they're committing a crime you know
and trying to escape and they're
attacking you and stealing your weapon
yeah
tough calls man tough choices it's hard
to know what the right move is and
people seem to think that if it were me
I know what I would do tonight no man
yeah everyone always loves to know that
they think they know the answers they
just want to put a play the blame game
look if you have an issue with police go
become a police
and be the cop that you want cops yeah
be yeah I don't see be the change you
want to see in the world
definitely yep exactly how many of these
people are like I'm gonna become a cop
so I can clean up the apartment
none of them no none of it dude it's
just like that meme of the feminists
where it's like you know the one reads a
paper saying not enough women in stem
yeah so she goes to college and the next
panel is her holding up Gender Studies
thing like protesting more women stem
like we go to school for stem yeah if
you want to be that in that industry do
it make it happen that is true if you if
you're like fighting for it
what are you really fighting where where
was it where the black lives matter
protest was all white people all the
cops were black you remember that I
don't remember where that was but
something did just happen yes all that's
confirmed sources confirmed that Atlanta
PD zones three and six southeast area
already have twenty to thirty cops walk
out that is half of an entire shift
what's the source on it that is Seth
weathers who reports for do weather core
there's like a weather weather dude
weather guy weather guy armed
that's my source is a weather guy so
take that what's is what's his Twitter
account that is set the weather's that's
his handle just like regulation weathers
regular set that is very easy to find
all right Seth was Seth weathers here
sometimes tweeting the truth weathers
Corp owner so can always say that he's
always tweeted it confirmed yeah yeah
I'll take his word for it sources can
source confirms Atlanta PD zones three
and six southeast area already have
twenty to thirty cops walk out that's
half an entire shift Bravo yeah those
cops Bravo
yes and up for yourselves man do it we
need more who are these other cops that
are staying there no no I don't I don't
think that's that's not fair at all you
don't think so no because there's there
are cops that are going if we leave then
we're gonna have fight the whole that
it's their town it's their city they
probably love it I'm sure they might be
the ones that I'm talking about like
could go up and fight and be that cop
that might be them that might be like
you know what no we're here to make a
difference we want to help our community
III they exist I know they do I've met a
few of them I have I have friends that
are
you know our cops and it's like they
they're not all bad there's good cops
yeah sure though the cops are walking
off are good cops too right sure but you
know it's like but you can't just call
the ones that are staying chickens that
is not fair at all well they need to
have a conversation then about why
two-thirds white three-quarters of them
are walking half of them sorry half of
them are walking off the entire shift
well I'm not saying I blame you I'm not
saying that Rickon is too strong but I
would really like to see them stand up
for what they believe I want all of them
to stand up for what they believe in and
if it takes a night of chaos I don't
want that I don't think they want that
either but maybe that's what needs to
happen I don't know I don't know I agree
that there's probably a political
difference between the cops and you
can't tell who's a coward who's a
chicken just because some want to stay
but I do think the ones thing are making
a huge mistake
notably because the left wants you gone
and the right wants you to stand up for
yourself right it is clear that the
extremes the extremists doesn't matter
if you're on the left or the right they
want the cops to be you know either
expunged or just to leave but you got to
remember that these are the extremists
these are people on the far sides of the
population and as everything we talked
about there's a bell curve most people
are in the Bell in the middle they're
like what is going on with these two
extremists yeah
I'm sure a lot of them are our police
officers are the same they're like man
what is going on here
Twitter is lighting up with a bunch I'm
sure I'm sure that way more zones have
walked off
mm-hmm but I gotta tell you man you do
not want to be and it's at Lana is
trending I'm sure it is how many how
much of this might just be a bunch of
people on Twitter all hooting at each
other and high-fiving each other about
what's going on and meanwhile the
Atlanta PDS and they're like we're doing
our jobs we talk about maybe who know
the South weathers guy says he's got it
confirmed some people on Twitter have
said that absolute dead air on Atlanta
PD zones five and six so I don't know I
wonder if anybody listening are you guys
in in Atlanta I guess I could pull up my
police scanner and see if
here anything yeah later look at the
average something yeah red state just
mentions the various reports yeah that
they're walking off following this
discharge this is their chance to take a
stand
they've an update they say the story
below has to do with the decision my
fault in County uh okay so they change
the title still you know I guess if Seth
weathers is saying it's confirmed then
that's the best we can say I have no
reason to challenge his uh you know
integrity sounds like happening man yeah
I don't want an actual source but across
the country cops have been resigning
it's exactly what the left wants the far
left I wonder what this means for
November we talked about the other day
that regular people in South Philly
there was another story earlier today
where a bunch of eighty black lives
matter protesters came to some small
town of 20 hundred people mm-hmm seven
hundred counter protesters showed up
weapons they were smacking people around
I wonder they call it the silent
majority but what's interesting is that
I often hear that from Trump supporters
as though the Trump supporters are the
silent majority technically true but I
think there's a better way to put it
regular Americans have had enough
absolutely regular Americans as matter
what they vote for yep exact all they
know is some crazy people show up to my
town smashing up my stuff yep and so I'm
gonna show up at the baseball that's
what I've been saying exactly go out and
to get out of the cities go to go to the
smaller man good yeah well I mean I'm
there every but we're talking about the
the antifa folk the the people that are
smashing stuff it's like yeah sure leave
the cities see what happens and go to
the small areas and start riling up
someone who will shoot you but you just
saw it and but you're not actually
telling anyone to do anything no no it's
definitely I'm not saying it I've been
I'm I was just referencing that I've
been saying that that's what's gonna
happen
yep they're gonna meet the the huge
force of what America is the average
American is like we're not gonna stand
for this now we're seeing it with some
baseball bats and crowbars mm-hmm oh
you're gonna come to our small town sure
come on sure we all know each other
we're gonna stop you 700 people 700
people in a town of 1,200 people yep and
a
black lives matter protesters were there
80 yeah 700 counter protesters like nope
yeah they're about to they're about to
be woken up yeah they want to be worried
w-well yeah well yeah you know one way
to wake someone up is to you know come a
nice little love tap on the back of the
head I guess yeah I'm kidding
but all right so look well I guess well
this is a crazy story
all right people are people are making
fun of the Atlanta Police they're
throwing a tantrum because they're being
held accountable oh please spare me do
you have no idea welcome to the purge
man thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you